-Ana, you are up.
Come over here and pull the mic.
No Whammies.
Come on, Ana.
-No Whammies.
-Yep.
-Trip, trip, trip, trip.
-Trip, trip, trip.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Musical Genre Challenge!
-Ohhh!
-♪ Musical Genre Challenge! ♪
-We know how this one works,
you're gonna get a song title
and a completely different
musical genre,
and then you're gonna have to
sing the song
in that style.
-Okay.
-Let's see what song you got.
-Come one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Blank Space," Taylor --
-That one --
-Taylor Swift as holiday jazz.
-Holiday jazz.
-You can go right over there
to that mic stand there.
-Right here?
-Do you know how to give it
a nice little --
-A little swing.
-Yeah, a little swing to it.
-A little holiday --
holiday swing?
-Yeah, yeah.
-A little holiday swing.
-One, two, three --
[ Holiday jazz music playing ]
♪♪
-♪ Nice to meet you,
where you been? ♪
♪ I could show you
incredible things ♪
♪ Magic, madness, heaven, sin ♪
♪ Saw you there and I thought
"Oh, my God, look at that face ♪
♪ You look like
my next mistake ♪
♪ Love's a game, wanna play?" ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ New money, suit and tie ♪
♪ I can read you
like a magazine ♪
♪ Ain't it funny? Rumors fly ♪
♪ And I know you heard about me,
so, hey, let's be friends ♪
♪ I'm dying to see
how this one ends ♪
♪ Grab your passport
and my hand ♪
♪ I can make the -- ♪
[ Scatting ] weekend!
♪ So it's gonna be forever ♪
♪ Or it's gonna go
down in flames ♪
♪ You can tell me
when it's over, ♪
♪ If the high was
worth the pain ♪
♪ Got a long list of ex-lovers ♪
♪ They'll tell you I'm insane ♪
♪ 'Cause you know I love
the players ♪
♪ And you love the game ♪
♪ 'Cause we're young,
and we're reckless ♪
♪ We'll take this way too far ♪
♪ It'll leave you breathless ♪
♪ Or with a nasty scar ♪
♪ Got a long list of ex-lovers ♪
♪ They'll tell you I'm insane ♪
♪ But I've got a blank space,
baby ♪
♪ And I'll write your name ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?
-Happy holidays!
-Come on, now!
Oh, my gosh! Ana Gasteyer!
That is how you do it, right
there, ladies and gentleman.
That is how you do it.